Now, I'd like to introduce our featured presenters today,
professors Jim Leape and Pamela Matson.
Jim directs with Fiorenza Micheli,
the Stanford Center for Ocean Solutions,
and is the William and Eva Price Fellow
at the Stanford Woods Institute for the Environment.
Jim has more than three decades of conservation experience,
spanning a broad range of conservation issues on every continent.
From 2005-2014, he served as director general of World Wildlife Fund International,
and leader of the Global World Wildlife Fund Network.
Before going to World Wildlife Fund International,
Jim directed the conservation and science initiatives
of the David and Lucile Packard Foundation.
Previously, he served as Executive Vice President of
World Wildlife Fund US, in Washington DC,
as a lawyer for the United Nations Environment Programme in Nairobi, Kenya,
as a law professor,
and as a litigator for the National Audubon Society and for the US Department of Justice.
He is also a distinguished fellow at the Climate Works Foundation.
Pamela is an interdisciplinary sustainability scientist,
academic leader, and organizational strategist.
A former dean of Stanford University School of Earth Energy and Environmental Sciences,
she is the Goldman Professor of
Environmental Studies and senior fellow at the Woods Institute for the Environment,
and leads the graduate program on Sustainability Science and Practice.
Her research addresses a range of environmental and sustainability issues,
including sustainability of agricultural systems,
vulnerability and resilience of particular people,
and places to climate change and characteristics of
science that can contribute to sustainability transitions at scale.
Some of her over 200 publications include: Seeds of Sustainability:
Lessons From the Birthplace of the Green Revolution and Pursuing Sustainability.
She's an elected member of the National Academy of Science
and the American Academy of Arts and Sciences,
and received a MacArthur Foundation Award among many other awards and recognitions.
With that, let's turn it over to Jim and Pamela.
Good morning everyone, thank you for joining us for
our strategies for sustainability program.
Today, we're going to be talking about a really important type
of social capital that allows us to address challenges,
very complex challenges that span sectors and span across spatial scales.
But before we start that conversation,
I think it makes sense to take a moment and ask,
what does sustainability mean?
What do we mean by sustainability?
Of course, this is a term that's used by different people in different ways, but, um,
it's very commonly used in the corporate world,
and their corporate sustainability is
about a triple bottom line or the three-legged stool.
It's about making decisions that make sense economically,
but also socially, and environmentally.
And today ESG is a central part of many corporations, ah, business.
Why do cor- why do corporations do it?
I should just say, it's partly because it saves money, it reduces risk,
helps recruit and retain the best of the, um, uh,
employees, and also is because corporations care about their communities in the world.
And the other organizations that use sustainability regularly is,
The International Development Community.
The, the community that's trying to help some of the poorest places on
the world- in the world develop socially and economically.
Over three decades ago,
it was recognized that if we want to help meet the needs of,
of the present, we have to do so without compromising the future.
So sustainable development became a major focus,
and it's been worked on for many many years with quite a bit of success.
Today, the world is focusing on the 17 SDGs,
or sustainable development goals of the UN.
Corporations, uh, governments, universities,
and other research organizations, NGOs,
foundations are all working together to try to address these goals.
What do they have in common?
They both, both uses of the term sustainability and others
are focusing on the well-being of people, and organizations.
But not just today,
also in the future,
and not just here where we live,
but all around the world.
And because of that common focus,
I'd like to think about sustainability as, ah,
sustainability goal as that of inter-generational social well-being.
So if we're using the word well-being of people,
what do we mean by that?
There's lots of different, uh, uh,
discussions about what is included in the term well-being,
but certainly it includes meeting the material needs of people for food and energy,
and water, and shelter,
and employment and so forth.
It means, um, addressing health issues and meeting educational needs,
and providing opportunities for people to choose, for example,
what they do with their life an- and security and so on.
If you think about how hard it is to achieve those,
that goal of inter-generational well-being,
the well-being of people not just today, but in the future,
you recognize the huge challenges,
but many of us also recognized the huge opportunities in doing so.
But it is not easy and the problem here is that these kinds of
questions that we're addressing for sustainability and
for meeting the inter-generational well-being of people around the world,
um, are, are really complex problems,
and they take place in highly complex systems.
There's lots of different players,
lots of different moving parts,
lots of interactions, feedbacks, non-linearities.
And the fact is,
intervening in one area may,
may have unintended consequences for other parts of the system.
So changing a policy could have impacts
in many places that you didn't expect them to occur,
or a new technology could also have unintended consequences.
So because of this complexity, um,
[NOISE] we believe that it's very
helpful to use systems approaches to do systems thinking,
and to utilize frameworks to help us design and
implement actions that address the goals of sustainability despite complexity.
So one such framework is this shown here, at,
at the top you see well-being,
the constituents of well-being,
we talked about before.
There are lots of production and consumption processes that we and you,
and all of us who are actors and agents of change,
are carrying out in trying- in trying to address that well-being goal.
We could spend hours, days,
years talking about how those production and consumption processes could change,
but today let's just turn to the fact that they, there,
they rest on five major asset groups.
These underlie our ability to produce and consume well-being,
they underlie our ability to meet that well-being challenge.
So start with human capital.
This is just the numbers of people or demographics,
um, the- the health of people,
the accumulated knowledge that people have,
and these are the things that allow humans to interact in complicated systems.
Social capital includes the rules and regulations,
the culture and cultural and social norms, uh,
the governance systems, the networks,
and the partnerships that allow us to work
together as we try to reach the sustainability goal.
Manufactured capital includes everything we make,
it's our roads and our airports,
and our energy plants,
it's our factories and the things that we make in those factories,
it's the new technologies that we're developing including, uh, you know,
our- our- our hand-held devices,
it's books, it's management practices,
anything that we make.
Natural capital includes everything that this planet offers us.
It includes ecosystems, on land and in
the oceans that provide so many of the things we need.
It includes: water resources and soil resources, our climate system,
our atmosphere system, and minerals that we draw on,
and many other things.
And then finally, the fifth major group of [NOISE] assets is knowledge capital.
This includes, the knowledge that we gained from scientific research,
but it also includes the knowledge we gain from,
from practice, from experience, from traditional knowledge.
So all of these things work together to underpin our efforts towards sustainability,
and if one of them is missing,
we're not going to probably make much progress.
In some places for example,
what's missing is the rule of law,
and it gets in the way of communities trying to move towards sustainability.
In other areas, it might be infrastructure.
In other areas, it might be depleted natural resources.
We need them all, and in many cases,
we have to develop them,
grow them so that we can meet our sustainability goals.
You have to pay attention to all of them.
Today, we're going to focus on social capital,
and on one particular type of social capitals,
rather new rather challenging,
and that is the use of partnerships to address really really complicated problems.
And to present this,
Jim Leape is going to take us through some cases and some experience that he's had,
as both a developer of these kinds of partnerships and someone
who's analyzing how well they work So Jim over to you.
Great. Thanks Pam.
As we, uh, live in an increasingly globalized economy, um,
the creation of social capital becomes evermore important,
and in many ways evermore challenging.
Um, and that's what we want to talk about a little bit, um, this morning.
Um, Is how do you create social capital,
in a globalized economic sector.
As all of us demand more and more from the Earth, um,
we're putting more and more pressure on producers to expand production
of commodities such as soy or beef or seafood or copper,
uh, and as they expand production,
they are putting more and more pressure on the natural resources,
the natural capital that supports us all.
Now in the context of fierce global competition in global markets,
it's often difficult for any one country to control those forces,
and to manage its own resources successfully.
And so a success will come from thinking
much more broadly about what kinds of collaborations,
what kinds of partnerships,
can actually drive change.
And this is a complex of ideas and possibilities that
some have called ecosystems of change.
It recognizes that in a globalized economy change comes from diverse actors,
not just governments, not just companies, but also NGOs,
civil society organizations of other kinds, communities,
international organizations, engaged with each other in an evolving set of interactions.
So those are interactions that may take one form early in
a change process then evolve significantly over time,
as these collaborators interact.
Um, and together are finding ways to create solutions that can meet these challenges,
and to drive those solutions into implementation
on a scale that really will change outcomes.
Now for all of us the touchstone in these efforts
is the sustainable development goals which provide us for the first time,
a global agenda for sustainability.
And these goals have become increasingly a touchstone
not only for government actors but also for many companies,
and for civil society.
One of those goals, um,
is the sustainable management of forests.
Ah, it's this goal that I want to focus on, ah, this morning.
Uh, this goal you will note,
um, calls among its many targets,
for an end to deforestation globally by 2020,
which is after all, uh, next year.
Um, and it's worth noting as we talk about collaborations in this space.
Um, but we are on a track to achieve that goal, in fact,
we saw a record levels of deforestation around the world in 2016 and 2017.
Um, but this is the target we've set ourselves and it is the touchstone,
for companies and civil society and others to come
together around trying to change the direction of those curves.
The big problem is clearing of forests for agriculture.
Seventy one percent of tropical and subtropical deforestation
comes from conversion of forest lands to agriculture.
And together, agriculture and deforestation account for
nearly a quarter of greenhouse gas emissions globally.
So this is a big problem from
a forest-wise perspective but also from a climate perspective.
One of the biggest culprits in driving deforestation is
palm oil especially in Southeast Asia.
And I'm going to focus on palm oil as a case study,
to look at how partnerships are beginning to form,
and where they might go from here.
We saw explosive growth in palm oil production over the last half century,
starting from virtually nothing in the mid '60s,
you see in the red line,
the growth of palm oil production first in Malaysia,
and then maybe 10 years later in Indonesia.
Indonesia itself alone accounts for
more than half of all global palm oil production today.
And this is a product which you rarely know you are buying,
but it is in half the products in the grocery store.
It's in little tiny type on the back of each package,
whether it is lipstick or cup noodles or peanut butter,
cup noodles [LAUGHTER] or peanut butter,
or soap or shampoo,
or many other products.
Um, and so it is on the one hand ubiquitous,
on the one hand hugely significant,
the most important vegetable oil on the global markets,
at the same time a very difficult challenge to tackle,
because nobody knows they're eating palm oil,
they don't think about buying palm oil.
And so for many years it was very hard to get,
um, at this problem.
And then in 2001, Migros,
which some of you from Europe will know is,
um, is a grocery chain in Switzerland,
Migros came to WWF and said,
How can we work together to address this problem
of unsustainable production of palm oil globally?
And out of that process,
out of that first engagement,
came a small collaboration with a handful of retailers,
and producers, and NGOs, Civil society organizations,
who came together to- to begin to develop
principles for sustainable production of palm oil.
And so was created the round table on sustainable palm oil, RSPO.
And RSPO, those parties and a growing number of stakeholders from each sector,
worked together over the years that followed to
develop a standard for sustainability in that sector.
Now if you think about it for a minute you realize that of
course that's a daunting undertaking, um,
because having all the stakeholders together is essential for credibility,
and could be essential for impact,
but it also makes it very difficult to get to agreement on what a standard should be.
And I think it's clear that RSPO has
worked very hard over the last 20 years or the last 18 years,
to develop a credible standard.
It has made huge progress in that time.
And it has also demonstrated that progress is challenging.
That is almost inevitably too slow for some actors,
and too fast or too strict for others.
And RSPO has been trying to wrestle those challenges to the ground.
Um, it has come up with a standard that is increasingly the touchstone in this sector.
But while RSPO wrestled with those difficult problems,
two other insights really changed the way civil society and
companies began to think about how- how change could happen in this sector.
And the first was a recognition coming out of WWF.
That they are in fact even in these huge global sectors,
keystone actors who really can be crucial in driving change.
So if you take the commodity sectors global,
not just palm oil but also soy,
and beef, and tuna,
and shrimp, you take those global commodity sectors broadly,
they of course have now seven-plus billion consumers.
All of us are consumers of products that come out of those sectors.
And they have maybe 1-1.5 billion producers,
fishermen, and farmers who are growing crops or catching fish around the world.
That's a pret- those are pretty big numbers,
pretty hard to influence directly,
the behaviors or practices of 1.5 billion farmers and fishermen.
But there is connecting those two groups,
connecting producers to buyers,
there is a supply chain that actually has a very pronounced choke point.
And there are about by [inaudible] estimate.
If you look across 15 commodities that are
the most important commodities for driving biodiversity loss around the world,
there are about 500 companies that control
70 percent of the production and trade in those sectors.
And that begins to become a very ma- manageable number.
That if you can reach those companies,
engage them supporting change,
you can begin to make a difference that matters globally.
And the second insight, um,
in this example comes from Oxfam,
the second insight is that many of those big companies have brands,
consumer facing brands, and they are often
highly focused on the integrity and reputation of those brands.
And that means that NGOs,
civil society organizations especially campaigners,
can engage companies by engaging their brands.
And so take two examples in the case of palm oil. One is Unilever.
Unilever has for a very long time been the world's largest buyer of palm oil.
It's central to soap and to margarine two of their core products,
but many other things they make as well.
And Unilever makes Dove beauty products.
And for many years their campaign, ah,
in supportive Dove beauty products has been the campaign for real beauty,
of which this ad is one example.
And so in 2008 Greenpeace took off on this ad,
to bring home the message that that Unilever was
buying palm oil and therefore was part of driving deforestation.
And this is an ad that hit Unilever pretty hard.
And this is an ad that goes to the direct directly to their brand positioning,
to their reputation, and the reputation that they have earned and continue to build.
And so within a few days,
Green- Unilever sat down with Greenpeace to begin to talk about,
okay how do they shift their purchasing to sustainably produce palm oil?
Greenpeace did the same thing with Nestle.
Nestle of course one of the most widely known brands in the food sector,
an iconic brand for Nestle is KitKat.
And if you haven't seen it it's worth going on YouTube and asking for Greenpeace KitKat,
you will get the video that lies behind this ad.
And what that video brought home in a very vivid way,
was that every time you, uh,
eat a KitKat bar you are part of deforestation.
That Nestle was part of buying palm oil and
therefore contributing to deforestation in Southeast Asia.
This hit Nestle hard and Nestle pushed back for two or three or four weeks on social media.
Then Greenpeace activists dressed as orangutans dropped out of the ceiling of the uh,
Nestle annual general meeting, um,
and brought home the- this connection, brought home this issue.
Talking to colleagues within Nestle and one thing that becomes clear is that
this initially felt like an attack on the company and of course it was.
But what they realized is that it also was a statement that Greenpeace, sorry,
that Nestle was part of deforestation and that
is not something Nestle wanted to be a part of.
So in the weeks that follow,
Nestle also made a commitment, uh,
to addressing deforestation in the supply chain.
And it has worked very intensively over
the last several years to deliver on that commitment.
So you have a couple of big companies, um,
that have begun to make commitments, that have said,
"We're going to address sustainability of palm oil production in our own supply chains."
But as they did that,
one thing became clear which is that,
it is very hard to do it as a single company,
to drive that kind of change as a single actor in a global and complicated, uh, sector.
And so Unilever and Nestle and
others began to realize that they needed to collaborate with their competitors.
So having been engaged with NGOs like Greenpeace and then
with WWF and others to figure out how to address this problem,
they realized that everybody would be better off if
the whole consumer product sector move together.
If, if Unilever and Nestle and other first-movers
were joined by other companies in their sector.
And that would be better for the forest because you'd get broader change,
a broader commitment to sustainability,
but it will also be better for each of them because they
reduce the risk that by moving on this issue,
they created a competitive disadvantage,
um, in the marketplace because others could buy palm oil more cheaply.
And so Unilever, in particular,
led the creation of a commitment in the Consumer Goods Forum to addressing deforestation.
Consumer Goods Forum which is about 400 companies adding
up to more than $2 trillion in revenues,
um, who work together on issues of concern to the consumer products in retail sectors.
In 2010, this Consumer Goods Forum committed to addressing deforestation and
the companies- in companies of Consumer Goods Forum
committed to eliminating deforestation from their supply chains,
focusing in particular on palm oil, also soy, beef,
and timber and paper production which are
the big drivers of deforestation around the world.
So for the first time, you have the whole sector moving and
saying we need together to be coming to grips with these problems.
A new kind of collaboration among companies that otherwise can
meet- compete very vigorously in the marketplace.
Okay. So that gives you the ultimate buyers,
the- the consumer products companies and
the retailers who are selling the ultimate products,
but all of them were supplied by traders.
And traders of course are largely behind the scenes.
Traders are companies like Wilmar and Cargill,
Archer Daniel's Midland who trade vast quantities of commodity,
who have for years traded commodities largely on the basis of quality and
price because that's how those global markets
work into our largely out of the public eye.
But as you saw more and more buyers,
more and more of their customers making commitments to eliminating deforestation.
As you saw the deforestation issue rise more and more on the public agenda,
with campaigns against some of those buyers and with broader campaigns.
Then the traders began to- to engage in this process.
They were hearing it from their customers that they needed a deforestation free supply,
they were hearing from campaign organizations and others that
this was a cause they needed to join.
And Wilmar, the largest single trader in palm oil, uh,
in 2013 announced that it was committing to be part of addressing
this problem and that it would eliminate deforestation from its supply chains,
um, over the years that followed.
So there you have it, you have the big buyers committed,
you have one of the biggest traders committed,
and then in 2014 the secretary general of
the United Nations convened a Climate Summit in New York.
Um, it was aimed at mobilizing action by actors across the spectrum,
by companies, by national governments,
by sub-national governments to address the challenge of climate change,
hoping to build momentum going into the Paris negotiations a year later.
And at this climate summit,
through the work of, uh,
NGOs in Indonesia, of the Chamber of Commerce in Indonesia, of buying companies,
trading companies, you saw the four largest producers of palm oil in Indonesia,
and remember Indonesia accounts for more than half of all global production,
you saw the four largest producers of palm oil in Indonesia step
up and say they too we're going to be part of this movement,
that they would commit to eliminating deforestation from their production.
So you get to 2014 that's well
13 years after Migros and WWF started the round table on sustainable palm oil,
that's six years after the first campaign against Unilever.
Twenty fourteen you have 60-70 some would guess 80 percent of the sector,
that is companies that account for 60 percent, 70 percent,
80 percent of production committed to trade- eliminating deforestation from this sector.
And that's a pretty remarkable moment, uh,
pretty remarkable to think that those companies,
that those actors and NGOs could all come together around
this cause in such a complicated and large economic sector.
And that led to the creation of something called the Tropical Forest Alliance.
Actually formally announced in 2012 and then expanded in the years that followed.
But a recognition that a pre-competitive collaboration among companies was crucial,
but that actually this- this is a cause that required all hands on deck,
that this required a collaboration among those companies,
among buyers and traders and producers,
but also that they be joined by civil society organizations,
both those who campaign on these issues and those who provide,
who engage with companies to help them figure out how to solve
them and it required participation by governments,
by governments of importing countries and by in
particular governments of producing countries.
And so for example, the Tropical Forest Alliance was joined
formally by the governments of Malaysia and Indonesia,
the two most important producers of palm oil as part of an effort
to broaden this collaboration and to find a way to make progress together.
At the same time you see technology come in and technology really will-
is already and will be increasingly fundamentally
important in creating the dynamics around these kinds of collaborations.
Um, Because as we know- as we get
more and more granular information about what's happening on the ground
and that information is
more and more real-time information or at least timely information,
then companies and governments and communities are more accountable,
and they are more able to take action that- on problems as they arise.
So for example, Global Forest Watch created by
the World Resources Institute developed something called the Palm
Oil Risk Tool which allowed- it made it
possible to identify risks in the palm oil supply chain,
where there were high levels of deforestation or fire.
Um, also create a facility that would allow- that would send you an alert,
whether you are a government official or a company or an NGO,
could send you an alert if a fire was spotted or forest was being cleared.
And these tools get more and more powerful every
year and make it more and more and more and more
possible to actually come to grips with these problems
together and hold each other accountable for progress.
Now, that's the story that took us up through 2014.
Um, you saw growing collaboration,
growing engagement among these different actors in trying to
come to grips with the challenge of deforestation on the ground in the palm oil sector.
And then in 2015 we had an El Nino year and crisis hit.
In that year, in August, September,
October there were more than a 100,000 fires across Sumatra and Borneo,
the two largest islands of Indonesia.
And those 100,000 fires were almost without exception intentionally set,
in most cases to clear land for agriculture.
But what happens in an El Nino year is that fires once set often burn out of
control and many of these lands have deep reservoirs of peat soil,
meters deep which is coal in the making and which can burn and burn and burn forever.
And so fires once started often just burn for weeks and
months and were very difficult to point- to put out.
Um, these fires were a climate catastrophe,
in the months of September and October 2015,
on most days, all those yellow bars,
on most days the emissions from these fires
exceeded the total daily emissions from the US.
So a huge amount of carbon put into the atmosphere over the course of these fires.
But these fires were also a public health and development catastrophe.
So the- the Harvard School of Public Health has estimated more than 100,000 people
will have shorter lives because of their exposure to the smoke from these fires,
I was in Singapore during the time of these fires.
While the air on those days was not too bad in Singapore,
in Malaysia the average concentrations of
small and fine particulates were about 300 parts per million.
The safety standard is a hundred.
So the average level in Malaysia was 300 and they had closed all the schools.
In some parts of Kalimantan,
the levels reached as high as 1,500 parts per million,
so 15 times a safe level.
So this was from a public health perspective,
never mind the climate impacts from a plu- public health perspective, a disaster.
It was also a development disaster.
The World Bank estimates that Indonesia took a 2 percent loss in
global domes- domestic product because of the damage of these fires.
And so all of a sudden you see all of these issues
come together concerned about forest protection,
about climates, but also about health and development,
all converged in the shared recognition that somehow
we collectively had to come to grips with the challenge of fire and deforestation,
uh, in- for palm oil production.
And so in that year,
President Jokowi shown here in this picture,
began to put in place restrictions, um,
to try and ramp up the government of Indonesia's efforts to address
the challenge of palm oil and in particular the associated challenge of fires.
Um, he impo- imposed a moratorium on the conversion of peat lands for example,
put in place a variety of other restrictions.
And so then you had governments more actively
engaged in this broad effort of coming to grips with this problem.
Now, there is hope on the horizon.
Um, last year, we saw a down tick in primary forests lost in Indonesia.
You see that it's been quite persistent over the last several years,
um, as demand for palm oil,
um, continues to put pressure on those forests.
It dropped last year.
Last year was a wetter year.
It wasn't as dry as 2015 and 2016.
So there's no question that weather helps reduce the level of, uh,
deforestation by keeping, by making it less likely that fires, er, will spread.
But I think it's also generally agreed that the actions taken to
def- to reduce deforestation also played a role in,
in beginning to bring that curve down.
I don't think anybody would say,
um, that we have now crafted the problem,
that we have turned the corner,
um, that the challenge of
deforestation in Indonesia and more broadly is behind us, far from it.
Um, but I think we are seeing that the kinds of
partnerships it takes to drive chains have been building,
uh, and the focus now is shifting to hadn't take
those global engagements and translate them to concrete change on the ground.
Uh, and here I think is an important part of thinking about social capital and
thinking about how social capital in
a global sector translates into real change in the forest.
Um, and that is a recognition that,
that those global commitments are the foundation for change.
But then you have to get down to the nitty gritty of
actually implementing change in real places.
And that's manifest now in, in, uh,
in an array of efforts that are all under the umbrella of what's called
the jurisdictional approach which is buyers and producers,
NGOs, communities, and local governments.
In Indonesia, it's the cabinet buttons,
the district governments within
a larger province who are working together to figure out concretely,
how do we end deforestation and fires in
this jurisdiction and what are each of us going to do to help make that happen.
And that allows everybody to get to the specifics of what it really takes.
It allows and it calls upon companies and
NGOs to convert a commitment to conservation which
sustainability into a compelling development proposition to
make sure that this is a movement that really does work for small producers,
large producers, local governments,
communities in the places where palm oil is grown.
It is deeply challenging.
Um, these are hard problems and it is hard to affect change,
uh, in a sector like this globally but even at that local level.
But I think there's broad agreement that that's where the future lies [NOISE] ,
that you need these global commitments as foundation
and as creating the ecosystem within which change
can happen and need to then translate that into
real terms for real people at a jurisdictional,
at a government level,
um, at a, in a, in a way that can work.
Um, so that's the story of palm oil.
It is,uh, it is one of
several examples of how partners are finding a way to work together in
new kinds of collaborations and to continue to work together
as they make progress or face challenges in an evolving partnership,
um, that is serious about change.
This is absolutely a team sport.
Um, and it's a team sport that requires that everyone on the team figure out a way to be
engaged with each other to figure out a way to forge these kinds of commitments.
From a business perspective, um,
there's no better voice on this than Paul Polman who was for
the last ten years the Chief Executive of Unilever and,
and really a leader in everything that I've
talked about from the Consumer Goods Forum Commitment,
to the Tropical Forests Alliance,
to the development of the jurisdictional approach.
Um, but going back to what Pam said at the beginning,
what Paul emphasizes is that this is about system change.
It's about changing the way markets work and
the responsibilities all of us have as consumers and citizens.
And in particular, about the role that business has to play in
that larger system to sustain the system that makes their business possible.
Um, and I think there's exciting potential in that.
And I think these are the kinds of efforts
that will not deliver faster easy solutions but
will be necessary to create
the social capital it takes to succeed in achieving sustainability.
Thank you very much Jim and Pamela for this very informative presentation.
And now we'll move on to answering your questions.
Okay so the first question we have here is,
what does it take to form a partnership like this and put it in motion?
Do you want me to start with that? [LAUGHTER].
You're the expert on that. [LAUGHTER].
Well, I think we both got a lot on that.
The, the, um, I think it's
important to recognize that the kinds of collaborations we're talking
about are deeply difficult because you're asking people to collaborate,
not only across organizations with- which is by itself challenging,
but actually across sectors.
And when you bring a big NGO, for example,
let's say a big activist NGO together with a big global company,
you find that you just, you have many,
many differences in basic culture in basic expectations
for how the organization works and the way that you relate to each other and,
and your expectations for roles in the world.
So that, so, so making these partnerships work and,
and you would find I'm sure similar things in,
in building partnerships between competitors,
right, and which have a different set of, uh, challenges.
So building these kinds of partnerships, number 1,
takes real commitment on both sides.
This is not a matter of signing an MOU, right?
This is a matter of real commitment to invest in what it takes to build a partnership.
And of course, like any relationship,
the heart of that is trust.
So the heart is, you know,
do- is making the commitment and making the investment to really
build trust between the two organizations which starts at the top.
I mean, in my experience at WWF, by far,
the strongest collaborations we had at least at
a global level were ones where there was a strong engagement,um,
between the CEOs as well as down through the ranks,
um, so that the signal was clear that the those organizations were serious.
Um, it requires of course then seriousness
about understanding what the interests really are on
both sides of the conversation and how you can work
together to bring those interests, uh, together.
So the- there's no magic here, um,
but it- but it is easily underestimated.
And I think the successes you see in a story like palm oil or
similar stories come out of that kind of commitment from
the top all the way down to really investing in building
understanding and building trust and then being able to make progress.
Yeah, let me just add to that.
I, I completely agree on the main points that it is trust.
And, and then the question is how do you build trust?
What does it take to build trust?
And, and, um, you know,
how do you- how do we make sure that the partners
in this are all credible and, and legitimate partners?
You know, that they're therefore the- at the similar benefits to humankind.
Um, and, um, but I think it is helped by the fact that some of the large,
uh, non-governmental organizations are really, um,
leading in a way are,
are working very hard recognizing that it,
it has to be the- that progress can only be
made if you can develop trust and develop long-term partnerships,
long-term, um, ah, understanding
of each other's points of view and, and respect for those.
So along the same lines, um,
someone asked, regarding the palm oil example,
I was recently at a clean tech conference where they
mentioned that it is very difficult for governments to actually
enforce guidelines in umbrella companies
and throughout the supply chain for sustainable palm oil.
How can one ensure that good intentions are actually followed on and tracked,
and are there technologies and processes that you have seen to help those?
Yeah. So I would say the- so this is an important point and, and, and, and i- it's,
it's characteristic of a global sector like
palm oil but also particularly a commodity sector where
the products traded is once it goes into the system that has
historically been, um, ah, invisible.
Um, it's been impossible to know exactly where it came from.
So I think two things there.
I mean, one is, um,
technology is increasingly our friend unless,
and so there's increasing transparency about where deforestation is happening,
and and inc- increasing ability to know,
you know, whose responsibility it is.
So I think that's a crucial first thing.
Um, we are increasingly getting the p- power to trace products,
um, or directly from production,
all the way through the system.
But then secondly, this is for me a good example of
the evolution of roles that I was talking about,
um, a few minutes ago.
You see that NGOs, who,
civil society organizations who were in the early days campaigning to, to,
to get attention to this issue,
now actually have quite an important role in making sure
that there's accountability for delivering on the commitments that are made.
And when we were- when I was at WWF, for example, many years ago,
we were periodically issued a scorecard that said here's how
every company is doing in implementing its commitments on, let's say, deforestation.
And, and a couple of CEO said to me,
"Could you do- find a way to do that every quarter
because it really keeps people's attention focused on it."
And,um, I think NGOs have quite an important role in
these phases of a process in being a vehicle for that kind of accountability.
Can I ask a question on that? [LAUGHTER].
Yeah, sure.
Just, just I'd love your tho- thoughts on
blockchain and its role on the accountability on these kinds of things.
So I think it's quite impressive there were
45 minutes into class and we're just now mentioning blockchain.
[LAUGHTER] That's an accomplishment in itself.
Somebody else probably would have asked. [LAUGHTER].
Yes, is, um, so I'm not a tech person. Uh, I'm a lawyer.
But one of the things you find is in traceability in discussions is
that sooner or later everybody mentions blockchain.
I think the broader concept of
distributed ledgers clearly has an important role to play, uh,
in providing a credible and accessible sort of chain of
custody as it were and the ability to track products or whatever.
Um, as [LAUGHTER] Tom Lehrer, the comedian once said,
"Life is like a sewer and what you'd get out of it depends on what you put
into it," [LAUGHTER] and blockchain is the same way, right?
Blockchain, it, it can make sure that,
that the train is clear but it can't assure you the quality
of the information input at the beginning or the product input at the beginning.
So you still need that complement to what the blockchain can do.
Thanks.
Yeah Because I dated myself with that alone.
[LAUGHTER].
So next question.
If given the time and scale of our current challenge,
we can't afford organizations to take 8-12 years to address issues like this.
So how can we accelerate this process?
You want to go first in that?
I'll just say, we have to learn.
Um, you know, I think we,
and obviously relationships take time,
uh, because they're based on respect,
they're based on listening, they're,
they're based on trust, and,
and so you can't fly in and fly out of a relationship and have trust happen.
But on the other hand,
I think for anything in the sustainability realm,
we'd better learn by doing and take home the best,
ah, lessons and shortcuts,
and not make the same mistakes twice.
[NOISE] Part of that, part of that,
uh,14 years was probably having to create some new approaches and,
and we'll have to continue to do that but we'd better learn. Yeah that.
No, no I think that's exactly right.
I mean, somehow, first of all,
these things are hard and complicated.
Right? And then I think,
after this sort of warm glow of commitments,
we all I think recognize that love.
Actually, translating those into changes is difficult.
And I think we have to make sure that we are from
these first efforts and actually learning how to do it faster and bigger.
And I think that's a big part of the challenge.
So in, in interesting way,
there's a role for the research community in that, you know,
really paying attention keeping track, analyzing,
evaluating, and sharing what's learned about what's being done.
Um, and that, that product of that effort,
can hopefully be useful to everybody who's engaged in this.
So, [NOISE] and that not to add on to everything.
[LAUGHTER] But that's a, that's a rich area for collaboration between
universities and the civil society sector governments, and especially companies.
And companies.
Because there's a lot to learn about from
companies who are driving these kinds of changes,
through their, through their business,
um, and I think a lot to learn together about how to do that successfully.
Okay. Thank you. Our next question,
is what role does social activism play in
forging these partnerships and kicking off these initiatives.
For example, would Nestle and Unilever,
had kept quiet if it weren't for the campaigns mentioned.
Yes. So, um, I think social activism is, is crucial.
And I think, one of the great strengths of the civil society sector,
is the diversity of organizations who are able to prove,
to therefore play diverse roles and driving change in a, in a process like this.
So there's no question that,
that campaigns were important in,
in directing attention to this issue and then actually
galvanizing action by, um, important actors.
Ah, and at the same time, it was crucial,
that there were big capable conservation organizations in
the position there help countries and companies translate those commitments into change.
Um, so that, that ecosystem in itself,
is actually quite an important part of this.
How can circular economy initiatives contribute to
the conversation and efforts around sustainability,
beyond its value as a best phrase for marketing and education?
[LAUGHTER]
[inaudible] [LAUGHTER] I'm not an expert on the circular economy but I think we can all agree.
It's, that's fundamental.
Right, I mean you, already we are with seven billion people,
we are straining the capacity of the Earth to support us.
And of course exceeding that capacity in many places and in many ways.
Hence, though our numbers and our demand in particular will only grow,
and so clearly we have to have an economy that is less linear.
Mine it, use it, throw it away,
um, and, and more circular.
And that's the key to many of the things we're talking about.
Yeah. It's interesting when you,
you look at how human population and consumption has changed.
Um, we had, ah,
a billion people on the planet in 1800,
two billion people in the 1920s,
three billion people in the 1950s.
Today, we have eight plus billion people.
We're probably going to level off around 10 or 11 billion people.
We worked like crazy,
to meet the needs of all those people during that very rapid growth phase,
and we didn't think about the problems of overusing resources,
throwing away important products.
We didn't create systems that were circular.
We almost didn't have to,
and probably we felt like we didn't have time to.
We were in a mad dash to me the needs are a rapidly growing human population.
Today, we know what the consequences are,
today we see the,
the leveling off of population,
today we recognize that we can't throw things away anymore,
that we have to use our resources,
um, much more intelligently.
And, ah, so the circle,
a circular economy initiatives are a huge prospective of a,
a huge factor in doing that.
It's not just using things more efficiently, reducing use but,
but and changing the kinds of materials we use, but,
but making sure that they are, um, never wasted.
So it's a, it's an exciting time. I think for that.
Right. Okay. The next question is,
how can we engage corporations and form these partnerships in
regions where civil activism and education around sustainability is lacking?
[NOISE].
Well, it's funny [LAUGHTER] partly, if partly,
um, anything that saves money, ah,
and that actually is,
is addressing the needs of people,
um, in areas where there isn't any activism are still gonna be drivers for this.
But the interesting thing about,
about Jim's case study is that,
you see a, a top-down, ah, force,
that is affecting what's happening in places where there isn't
activism or where there isn't a community based interests and sustainability.
Um, it's a global world and it's a global problem.
Um, but I also think that the recognition,
that there are real benefits to doing things differently, [LAUGHTER] that there are,
there are benefits in terms of meeting the needs of people,
saving money, um, and, ah,
and in many other areas make it, um,
that alone a driver,
even if people don't put the sustainability term on it.
Yeah. I think the only thing I'd add to it is, I,
I think a fundamental principle to any offer like this,
is that you, you have to be able to frame issues in
terms of resonate with the audience and in the place that you're talking about.
Hence, and that means,
you know, so for example, in,
hu- human health has been a much better entry point for many of these issues,
then force protection or biodiversity conservation lies in many markets.
And, and you need to be able to talk and human health terms or what is,
why is this important for human health?
And you need to be able to reach people on those terms.
So to take it for China for example,
China is the largest buyer of many commodities around the world,
but Chinese consumers are increasingly
concerned and particularly with food, about food safety.
And that takes them traceability.
That takes them to wanting to know more about how the things they buy were produced.
And so the entry point in China on these issues
may well be through traceability in food safety as,
as opposed to initially through force protection.
But in each case, it's a matter of what,
what are people worried about and how are the,
how do you frame this issue in a way that will resonate.
Like wise, you know,
many farmers around the world who would like to
save money on the inputs they use in agriculture,
it costs a lot to fertilize.
Ah, but if, ah,
at the same time by doing so,
by reducing how much fertilizer you have to use, there're tremendous,
ah, benefits for the environment,
and so it's a win-win,
and there are lots of win-wins.
Our next question is, how can you contribute to
such initiatives and create social capital at the individual level?
Yeah. This is it.
It in basically every part of one's life, you can contribute.
I think, and we have this conversation a lot in an educational institution like Stanford.
How can we as individuals, how can we as a,
as a, as a community,
um, make a big difference?
And, uh, simply by the choices of what we eat,
and what we drive,
and, and how we, um,
how we think about our resource use, etc,
we contribute individually and,
um, we by doing so,
can build a social movement among our communities,
among our friends, among our families.
That is a very much a bottom-up.
I think there is another question about how we as individuals can, can,
can create change at a,
at a scale that affects more communities.
And that might be through your company,
driving, driving change in a company or in an,
in an organization, encouraging, um,
people to think more systematically about what's needed.
Uh, becoming systems thinkers I think is a key to that.
Yeah, I, I, I agree with that.
Interest to translate that into the palm oil case.
I mean, the, the first of all,
when we talk about what can people do,
people usually think first about voting and
voting is crucial right in any part of the world.
Right, voting really matters.
Because in the end, governments are and have to be at the center of this.
But one of the things you see in a case like palm oil is that consumers,
the decisions you make everyday in the grocery store,
the vote you cast and the way you,
in the products you choose really matters.
And, you know, when you,
you look at the IRA glass that I showed and those 500 companies,
it's easy to feel maybe disempowered while it's superimposed companies that matter.
But those companies are listening to you.
Right, I mean, those companies are very attuned to what their consumers,
their customers are thinking.
And so how you,
what you do in the marketplace,
even if you do it quietly, really matters.
And if beyond that,
you ask your retailer, so, you know,
what are you doing about palm oil or about seafood or about those messages get back?
So I think then you can actually do
all the thing being talking about the choices you make,
really do a ripple through the system to these large levers.
Great, thank you. Unfortunately, we're getting close to the hour.
So we'll have to wrap up the Q&A session.
Thank you very much Jim and Pamela for
sharing your knowledge with our participants today.
For those of you who have indicated an interest in the program,
our team will be reaching out with more information and you can
always visit us at globalimpact.stanford.edu.
Thank you all for joining us today,
and have a great rest of your week.